ALI AFSHAR: Today we're going
to be doing Office Hours for
the Google Drive SDK.
My name's Ali, this is Claudio,
and this is Alain.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Hi.
ALI AFSHAR: And we're three
engineers on the Google Drive
SDK developer relations team.
So we're going to get
started today.
If you don't know about Google
Drive SDK, we do our support
on Stack Overflow.
We find it's really useful to
get community engagement, and
today we're going to go
through some of the
interesting questions, and our
experts here are going to
answer them for you.
So let's get started
right away.
The first question I've got is,
is it possible to get the
owner for a Google Drive file?
That's pretty self-explanatory.
I won't go into the detail.
We have a sharing system in
Google Drive, and part of that
sharing system is an owner.
Could you describe that slightly
for us, Claudio?
How the permission
system works?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So for each
file you have, our users can
have access to that file
with different roles.
So obviously one of the users
will be the owner of the file,
the guy who created the file.
Or you could also transfer
ownership to another user.
But also, you can have other
people allowed to access the
file in a read-only mode in
their readers, or in a
read-write mode in their
editors of writers.
So what this guy's trying to do
is to have a programmatical
way to find the owner of
the file in Drive.
Let's say there are actually
two ways to
do it at the moment.
With the Google Drive API, the
new API we recently launched,
each file has a set of metadata,
and that metadata
includes a field called user
permission, which will list
what the permission for
the current user is.
So with this field, you can just
find out whether you are
the owner or not, or if you're a
writer of if you're a reader
on that file.
A broader solution would require
using the documents
list API, which is the older
API that interacts with the
same resources that the
Drive API works with.
And with the documents list API,
you can request ACL, so
access control list feed for
each file or resource, and
then from there, you will see
all the users that are listed,
and for each of them, you can
get what permissions they
have, all users and
groups as well.
ALI AFSHAR: OK.
And what happens if a file
doesn't have an owner?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: I'm not
sure that's possible.
ALI AFSHAR: That's a trick
question, sorry.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: I'm not sure
that's possible, because
you cannot delete the owner.
You can pass the ownership
to someone else.
ALI AFSHAR: Exactly.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: But you
cannot delete the owner.
ALI AFSHAR: So all files in
Google Drive must have at
least one owner.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
I mean, this is something that
happened in the enterprise
environment.
Let's say you, in your company,
have documents, and
one document is owned by one
of the employees, and the
employee leaves the company.
Of course we need to assign
that document ownership to
someone else.
So domain administrators can
change the ownership of a
document using things like
super administrator
permissions, and they can still
take ownership of the
document so that the document
is not lost.
ALI AFSHAR: Fantastic.
Thank you very much.
Let's get on to our
next question.
Does anyone know if the Google
Docs API supports commenting?
I'm trying to build an app that
allows me to add comments
and tagging to files
on G Drive.
Now if you've ever used Google
Docs, you know that there's a
pretty cool-- well, we think
pretty cool-- commenting
system, in that you can write a
comment against any piece of
text in a document, and then
people can reply to those
comments, and people can
resolve those comments.
And it's a really good way of
collaboratively iterating and
working on a document.
Now this question is asking,
can you programmatically
access the comment stream
using the Google Docs or
Google Drive API?
Alain?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Well,
unfortunately this is not
available through any of our
APIs, or anywhere through the
documents list API,
nor the Drive API.
But it's actually a good
feature to have.
So we are discussing having it,
and we hear your feedback,
and we'll get back to you
as soon as we have
more updates on that.
ALI AFSHAR: It's one of the
more requested features.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: I mean, it's
something people love in
Google Docs, is that they can
add comments and collaborate
on the same document.
And actually it's probably worth
mentioning that you can
only have comments on native
Google Docs, right?
ALI AFSHAR: That's right.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So you can
store any kind of files on
Google Drive, but you only
collaborate on them and add
comments with native
Google Docs.
So there's also a second
part of the question.
ALI AFSHAR: Now they're asking
for a tagging API.
I'm not sure exactly what that
means, but I guess it means
it's trying to work out a way of
adding custom metadata, ie,
application-specific,
non-Google Drive
metadata to a file.
Claudio, you're going to
answer that for us?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, because
I suggested something
on Stack Overflow, and
so there's no way to
[? outcast ?] some metadata.
But there is a field that is
called description, which is a
string field, so you can
basically put whatever you
want, any kind of data there.
And I assume that this
question was
about string tags.
Developers can use the
description field, which is
available through the docs list
API, the documents list
API, and store, let's say, a
space-separated list of tags
or a comma-separated list of
tags there, and then build
their logic, assuming that the
description is actually a
container for tags.
ALI AFSHAR: Now the beauty of
using that description field
is that when you then search,
either in the docs user
interface-- the user can do
a search just by typing--
or if you do a search query
using the documents list API,
that description field
is queried.
So if you put 20 tags, and one
of them is banana and one of
them is fruit, if you do a
search for fruit, your
documents will appear.
So it's not just a hack.
It's actually a pretty good
way of tagging and then
retrieving the data that
is tagged with that.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: I'm actually
thinking about a kind
of hacky solution,
another one.
ALI AFSHAR: Bring it on.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So you know
with the Drive API, we have
indexable tags that third-party
applications can set.
Tags are not exactly indexable
text, but maybe you can still
want to use them.
And any piece of information you
put in the indexable text
will be searchable as well.
So you'll have about the same
functionality using another
field, which is also available
with the new API.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: [INAUDIBLE]
is that the indexable tags is
write-only.
So neither the user or the
developer has access to this
field once it is set.
So if you want to tag a document
without it being
displayed to other applications
or the user, this
is the way to go.
If you want the user to see the
tag and appear on the web
UI in other applications,
you should use
[? VA Description ?].
ALI AFSHAR: So we mentioned
indexable text, and we know
what that means.
Can you explain what indexable
text is, Alain?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes, so the
Drive API lets you create two
types of documents.
You can either choose to store
the data behind the file on
Drive or store the data in your
own server if you already
have an existing application
and an existing database.
One of the cool features on
Drive, on the web UI, is to be
able to search documents.
But if data is stored on your
backend, we have no way to
know what's storing your data.
So developers can set data in
the indexable text field so
that Drive knows how to index
your files, and users can
search your files and
have them appear
on the search results.
ALI AFSHAR: OK.
Thanks.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Maybe another
question related to
that is that, can you add
indexable text to any kind of
documents, or any
kind of files?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: I would
suggest that it's used only on
the shortcut, but I believe
you can set that on both.
ALI AFSHAR: So I think you can
set it on both, but obviously
there's a problem there, because
documents that Google
Docs knows about and stores
there, sometimes Google Drive
does do indexing of its own--
for example, a photo,
something like that.
It sets the indexable text.
So if you in the API set the
indexable text, then you're
overwriting, potentially,
what we've got written.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
But if you have a banner
file format that--
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah,
we've done that.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: I mean, your
application is the only
one that uses it, and you're
sure that we don't understand
anything out of it.
Then you should probably provide
us with indexable text
so that we can give
users [INAUDIBLE].
ALI AFSHAR: So, very much
depends on the use case.
If you do have this use case,
get in touch with us, and we'd
love to talk to you about it.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And by, well,
when we say talk with
us, remember next week
is Google I/O.
ALI AFSHAR: Absolutely,
Google I/O.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: It's our
main event of the year.
It's next week in San Francisco
at the Moscone Center.
We're all going to be there, and
we'd love to meet you and
to, well, get your
feedback there.
And of course, there will
be announcements.
ALI AFSHAR: Of course there
will be announcements, as
there are every year at I/O.
So, come and find us.
We'll be in a Drive area if
you're attending that.
So we'll all be there, as will
some of the important people
in the Google Drive
[? UK ?] system.
So this is really your chance
to come and speak to us face
to face and tell us how great
we are, or tell us what we
could be doing better.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Better to best.
[INAUDIBLE].
ALI AFSHAR: So, yeah,
but please just
keep it to good feedback.
So, next question.
I think we've got time
for a couple more.
How to share a file to other
people using the
Google Drive SDK.
So, you've seen our
sharing model.
Claudio has spoken about how you
retrieve the permissions.
This is the other side of it,
how to add a permission to a
Google Drive document.
Who wants to talk about this?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: You.
ALI AFSHAR: Me?
OK.
So, as Claudio said, we've
got access control lists.
Currently at the moment with
the Drive API, you can't
perform this functionality.
You will need to use the Google
Documents List API.
Now, each document has a feed
that is essentially the
permissions.
We call them ACLs in the
Documents List API.
And each of those permissions
has a person or a group of
people or a domain that it
applies to, and it has a role
associated with it.
So you can say, I want
the domain google.com
to be able to read--
that's the role--
this document.
And additionally, we have
other little roles like
commenting and that
kind of thing.
It's all fairly well documented,
so check that out.
So how do we add it?
Well, essentially just post to
the ACL feed for a document,
and that will do that.
There's an extra thing there.
In some situations,
you might have--
well, in two specific
situations.
One, you may have to add many,
many files, give one person
permission to do many,
many files.
Now, there's two quick
ways of doing that.
The first one is you
can do batching.
OK, so we allow batching
of ACLs.
You send 100 at the same time
for the same file and that
just saves you making
many requests.
The other way of doing it is
you can move or create a
folder and copy all these files
into that folder, and
then just share the folder.
So again, that will save
you some time.
So there are some little
tricks with this.
But currently you can't use the
Drive API unfortunately.
Use the Documents List API.
This is one of our most popular
functionalities
because it's really good
to automate that.
If you're in an organization,
you don't really want to do
that one by one in the
Drive User Interface.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: I think it's
very important to stress
again that the Drive API and the
Documents List API work on
the same resources.
So you can mix the two.
They have a different
security model.
You can use one of them or the
other according to your needs.
But I mean, if you need to use
the Documents List API and
you're worried that your user
has upgraded to Drive, there
is no problem at all there,
because they all
use the same files.
ALI AFSHAR: With the same files,
with the same IDs, it's
the same data.
So what you do in one will be
reflected in the other.
It's exactly the same data.
OK.
Great.
Thank you, Ali.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Thank you, Ali.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: How to build
a desktop client for
Google Drive?
ALI AFSHAR: It's one of
my favorite questions.
How to build a desktop client.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: We've
heard it so many times.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah.
I want to build a desktop
application for Windows OS and
use Google Drive to save
some data in the cloud.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: I would say
download a Google Drive
application for Windows
that we provide.
ALI AFSHAR: So that's
a great answer.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: That's
ALI AFSHAR: But perhaps this
user just wants a bit of Drive
functionality.
They just want to save some data
to Drive, and they don't
necessarily want to--
Actually, again, our Google
Drive client would be the best
way because your application
could just copy it to a file,
and we'd handle the sync.
But if you really want to do
it yourself, currently, can
you do this with the
Google Drive API?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Unfortunately, no.
The Google Drive API requires
that a user install the
applications from the
Chrome web store.
There have been many debates
about why we need to do that,
so we are working on improving
the story here.
But right now, the current
situation makes it impossible
to use a Drive API for
a desktop client.
ALI AFSHAR: So what would
this user use?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Well, as
Claudio and I mentioned
earlier, [? to ?] document this
API, which works on the
same resources and allow users
to write actually a desktop
client that doesn't need to be
installed from the Chrome web
store, and can work on the
same type of resources.
ALI AFSHAR: OK.
Thanks.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: This question
is also very specific
about C++ and Windows.
Do we have any problems
with those?
ALI AFSHAR: No, we love C++,
and we love Windows.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So we must
say that there's no client
library for C++ that
we provide.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Google-supported client library.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: But the
protocol is described in the
Docs, and they're all
HTTP requests.
ALI AFSHAR: HTTPS requests.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
HTTPS requests.
So you can easily build your
client in any language.
ALI AFSHAR: Any language that
can parse XML, essentially.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes.
ALI AFSHAR: It can send
requests over HTTP.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah.
ALI AFSHAR: So, sorry C++ users,
we do get that question
occasionally.
As far as I can tell from C++
developers, they love writing
code anyway.
So Alain?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Well,
I do love C++.
Too bad I haven't really done
C++ in a long time, but as
Claudio mentioned, the APIs, the
REST API, you just need an
HTTP client to send data through
the wire, through the
HTTP, and read data from the
API for HTTP as well, or
HTTPS, and parse
and write XML.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, thank you.
So next question, possibly our
last question, because we'd
like to talk about it a bit.
The question is, I'm using the
Docs upload view in the Google
picker to upload documents
to the Google Drive.
However, I want to add content
to the description and the
indexable text fields at
the time of uploads.
What would be a simple
way to do this?
So, Claudio, first, if--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: I think we
should explaining what the--
ALI AFSHAR: Explain what
the picker is.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
What a picker is.
ALI AFSHAR: And then,
Alain, or one of you
can explain the answer.
So what was the picker?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: The Picker
API is one of the APIs we
provide to developers.
It's part of the Google Drive
SDK, and it is a JavaScript
API that you can use in your web
pages to get, upload, or
download file picker dialogue
for free from us.
So with a few lines of code,
you can integrate your web
application with Drive and list
your files, or as in this
case, you're also allowed to
upload files to Drive with a
simple drag and drop from your
browser, or it can have the
come and browse dialogue
from your environment.
ALI AFSHAR: So I'm getting
that right, Claudio?
Someone can just add two or
three lines of JavaScript.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Let's say 10.
ALI AFSHAR: 10 lines of
JavaScript to their page, and
they will be able to pop up a
dialogue that looks exactly
like a Google Doc dialogue.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Well, it
doesn't look exactly, because
it is exactly the same
dialogue we use.
And it's about 10 lines of
code, because you have to
write maybe seven lines to
define the features you want.
Let's say you want to
upload, or not.
Let's say you want--
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
[INAUDIBLE].
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Multiple views.
You want multiple uploads
at the same time.
And then you have to define a
callback that is the one that
is called when the upload
process is complete, or when
the user has selected a file.
And yeah, we have sample
code in our Docs.
And we also recently published
a blog post showing how to
have both upload and picker
in the same dialogue.
ALI AFSHAR: So now that we
know what the picker is,
what's the upload view?
What, you mean you can upload
files as well even in picker?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, so by
using this, you don't need to
write code to upload
files to Drive.
If you want to, you can just
pop up this dialogue using
those few lines of
JavaScript code.
And then the user can drag files
on it, and those files
will be added to the user's
Google Drive account.
ALI AFSHAR: Fantastic.
So you don't need to write
any more code to do that?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, in
order to insert a file, the
API requires you to send a post
request with specific
parameters in the payload,
and different
parameters of the request.
With this, you just need to
say, I want an upload
dialogue, and when the user is
done, I want to do this, which
is a callback.
ALI AFSHAR: OK.
Perfect.
So I won't rush an
extra question.
I think that's [INAUDIBLE].
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: No, there's a
second part of the question.
ALI AFSHAR: Oh, is there
a second part?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, the
second part was how to add
some metadata to the
uploaded file.
ALI AFSHAR: That was
the important pant.
My apologies.
How do you add extra data for
the description or indexable
text fields?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And the
question is specifically about
description and indexable
text fields we
talked about earlier.
And unfortunately, the
answer is you can't.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: With
the Picker API.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: With
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
No, you can't.
ALI AFSHAR: So how would
you do it, Alain?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Well, if
you want to write, like, a
full client-side application
only in JavaScript, you can
use the JavaScript client
library that Google supports,
which also can [INAUDIBLE]
Google Drive API.
So once the files are uploaded
to Drive, the callback will
provide you with a file ID, and
you can use this file ID
to send an update request to the
API to add the description
and the indexable text.
That will require
two requests.
That's unfortunate, but might
be the easiest way to do it.
And the client library's very
easy to use as well.
A few lines of code, I would
say one or two lines for
authorization.
And this should be handled
already by your code.
And the same thing, a few lines
of code to send the
update request.
ALI AFSHAR: Perfect, OK.
Perfect.
All right.
Sorry to cut you off halfway
through that one.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: No worries.
ALI AFSHAR: Right.
Thank you for coming to
our Office Hours.
There's just a few questions.
We'll have different types of
GDL, Google Developer Live,
events throughout the course of
the week, and every week,
but hopefully we'll
be repeating this.
So keep asking your Stack
Overflow questions.
We enjoy answering them
on Stack Overflow
and online as well.
So thank you very much.
See you at I/O if
you're coming.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yeah,
hope to see you at I/O.
ALI AFSHAR: So goodbye
from me.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Goodbye.
The events will be
a live stream at
Google I/O live stream.
So if you're not attending
in person,
please follow us online.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And this
is the time for a
shameless plug, right?
ALI AFSHAR: What do you
mean a shameless plug?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: When we say
that Alain and I are going to
present about Android
development for Drive at I/O.
And we know we've got so many
questions about it, so we're
going to talk about
it next week.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Exciting time.
ALI AFSHAR: Shameless plug.
ALI AFSHAR: It's not even
shameless if you're into
Android and you want to
write Drive apps.
Come along and see these guys.
There will be other
talks as well.
Great, so thanks very
much, everyone.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Thank you.
ALI AFSHAR: And goodbye
from us.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Bye.